yeah i would choose this over that
this is for dark time
hi i'm alvin hi i'm chris and we're
gonna swap some snacks today
so i'm from curacao it's a dutch carbon
island right off the coast of venezuela
today i'm excited to show alvin some of
my snacks i'm chinese american but i was
born and raised in california i might
not have the most traditional snacks but
i'm also excited to show chris what i
like to eat when i grew up all right
chris let's see what we brought for each
other let's do it one three and three
one two three whoa what is that this is
a cashew nut treat how does it look to
you it looks like a pile of like dough
what's this called actually i want you
to try to pronounce okay so it's oh
right here tenta lyra that's actually
pretty good okay it's called tinta
oh see he has the cool accent i can't do
that tenta means to tease
means above t is above doesn't make
sense
what do you think this is i see there's
a bagel there so what that is is that
chicken nuggets on top of it yeah so
this is a everything bagel with like a
little bit of cream cheese and dino
nuggets so this is something i would
come home and as a kid you just like
want to make stuff taste good right and
you don't really care how bad it is for
you so i would eat this after i came
home from school that's cool because i
brought my snack it's like a traditional
kurosawan thing but yours looks like
your own mine is not traditional by any
means all right should we swap let's do
it all right let's swap here we go
oh it kind of feels like dough like if i
made pasta dough and like let it sit out
and then dry it up too long overnight
that's kind of what it feels like
what does it taste like kind of like
marzipan
but there's like nuts and sugar it does
feel and tastes familiar like nut paste
we maybe have in china so it's good i
like it
that's exciting
i'm gonna go ahead and try yours often
this is your creation nobody else yeah i
like this 100 mine
you know this reminds me of a nugget
bread that i would eat
okay at the canteen they would sell
nuggets and bread oh cool so this is
essentially what it is without the cream
cheese i think that's a good addition
great it's nice i like that i'm glad
something unorthodox can remind you of
something that you grew up with yeah
that's awesome i like it yeah well i
can't believe he liked it so if you were
to name this dish alvin what would it be
called the heartburn era
next snack next snack let's do it two
three
reveal oh wow
that's cool kind of looks like it's like
some sort of peanut sugar candy right
that's essentially what it is okay cool
i want you to try to pronounce the name
because that's the most exciting part
panseku that's pretty good it's panseiku
yeah pan means bread
which doesn't make sense again
i don't know what seiko means and this
you can also get it at the market about
a dollar too so is this something that
you kind of had growing up actually no
because this is one of the the snacks
that i did not like growing up oh
yeah so you would get it always at
parties too as a kid i didn't think it
looked appetizing so i wouldn't eat it
yeah now it's i think it's kind of cool
alvin what do you have here for me i
think this is minty chocolate yeah so
it's andy's chocolate it's kind of like
these small little green bars it's like
chocolate in the middle there's like a
mint-ish layer right and basically why i
brought these is because i grew up
eating these without knowing what it was
so i would always look forward to going
to olive garden because they had these
excitedly eating your pasta and like
waiting for the check to come so that
you get the little green like chocolates
and because they're so good right so
this was basically like your main entree
for it yeah like i was like
not because i wanted pasta because i
wanted these chocolates i'm excited to
try this yeah can i go for it it's gonna
swap that swap yeah all right let's do
it yeah we see the layers mmm all right
here we go one two
yeah this is good it tastes like
something my grandpa used to make in
chinese cooking some dishes involve
boiling peanuts it's a very specific
taste that's awesome it's a good in
between
what you identified it as when you saw
it but then you when you tasted it it's
uh something more nostalgic
a lot of nostalgia here yeah unexpected
nostalgia from treats i would have never
eaten that's wonderful this is great
this is wonderful i want more yeah it's
like cleansing you kind of want to eat
warm next one next one let's do it all
right snack number three let's do it one
two three
whoa
yeah what what does it look like to you
it looks like a steak
like i can tell if i look closer there's
a lot of sesame maybe another like sugar
based like candy where you kind of mix
it together and you get like nutty and
sweet flavors does that sound about
right that that is okay that's exactly
what it is with some sesame seeds in
there as well this i'm very excited for
you guys
um all van it's spelled
z-j-o-z-j-o-l-i
jojo perfect
no that's is that right that's exactly
no way wow you got it right
i was kind of kidding but all right yeah
that's it i'll have one jojo lee please
so i was in curacao and i was asked
are you still in curacao um bring some
snacks yeah so i just shot some and i
brought them here i'm excited to taste
this one too yeah that's awesome so have
you had this at all i have had it but
not recently okay so it'll be like
awesome for you it would be awesome for
me too great i'm excited what do you
have here alvin what do you think this
looks like macaroni in there yes is this
cilantro that's not parsley okay ground
beef yeah it's it's craft and ground
beef it's weird to say this is a snack
but i would eat this when i come home
from school i was a very large and plump
kid so this was a snack and i still ate
after this all right yeah
nice all right chris uh what's the best
way to eat this you have to cut it first
you're gonna have a hard time doing so
but oh
that's a okay um
oh man this is some hard rock
all right oh no the paper towel got
stuck
oh no alvin you're ruining this entire
operation i wonder what jojo means now
that's the sound i'm gonna make when i
realize i got this stuff
no
all right i'm gonna try this now
[Music]
what do you think it's like sesame seeds
and sugar but both are very toasted so
the sugar is caramelized pretty high so
you get like
not a burnt but like caramelly almost
like smokiest sugar flavor kind of
sticks to your teeth though but that's
the fun of it just like the paper towel
so for this you kind of got to mix it up
a bit because i would like to throw
things and use the kid you just got to
mix it up so the bowl is kind of full
but you know you just kind of got to get
in there and i cannot believe i would
eat that
no this is good i like it as you said
it's exactly what you think it would
taste like this is ground beef or ground
turkey it's ground beef yeah i'm vegan
oh sh
just kidding
i got scared for a second all right last
snack that snack here we go ready three
one two three
oh cool
you have some uh uncured ham there too
with some cream cheese yeah that's
exactly what it is that's awesome i love
how mine is just so obvious and blatant
and yours is like actually cool what is
that to me it looks like toffee like
because i love toffee so like to me just
looks like chunks of chocolate and
toffee and just like the other ones it's
some kind of nut can you guess oh it's a
nut yeah cut a nut looks like this
i don't think i've had this nut before
hopefully i'm not allergic to it what is
it it's coconut actually oh come on that
doesn't count as a nut what the heck
[Laughter]
this name makes sense but at the same
time it doesn't sure so it's spelled
d-j-e-n-t-i
and
k-a-c-h-o i want to say
gentile cacho pretty good jinti kacho
gentika so it's like this way right and
it translates to dog teeth oh that makes
sense right at least it's like two words
that go together you know and you know
what it is you're not teasing any sky on
this one exactly it looks really
appetizing it looks like you could
something and grab a handful and just
keep eating yeah i did grow up eating
jintikajo and it's actually one of my
favorites too oh good oven so you have
ham here yeah uncured ham to be specific
and then you have some cream cheese the
story behind it is that when i grew up
as a kid i realized it tasted really
good with cream cheese cause it's so
salty this is sweet this is creamy and
neutral so i would eat it together and
be like oh this is good cool yeah let's
try this
so let's swap yeah and then you just
like spread some on it and you just like
eat it as like a roll up or you just
like put it on it you just straight up
eat a whole slice there you go yeah just
take both both okay yeah that's you
that's the way it goes and you gotta
yeah use your spoon get your spoon and
okay so this is what the spoon is for
yeah yeah that sounds weird okay good
ratio all right
[Music]
i don't like it i think i would like
this actually if it's like if i have
some bread with it yeah but i don't know
how you can eat this with the ham and
like straight up cream cheese so this is
kind of how i would eat it you know you
take them take a slice you sort of like
use it as like a spread you just kind of
do that okay okay and then you just kind
of roll it up
okay let's see let's try it
roll up i'm pretty sure there's sort of
fancy versions of this at like parties i
feel like this will be good
after eating that yeah i'm gonna get a
piece it smells good i like this one you
like it yeah it's like fatty
sweet chewy ish like buttery and sugary
kind of all the things i like why does
it remind me of pork ribs
yeah this is my favorite this is your
favorite fashion not a second the second
but this is really good i think if you
fed it to someone who didn't grow up
eating what you ate or knowing what you
knew it's like more of a crowd pleaser
kind of safety kind of dish so okay i
like it yeah i would choose this over
that
this is for dark time so what would you
say out of the ones i brought you today
one through four so andy's is my number
one from everything you brought today
it's just like the mint chocolate and
it's not necessarily like any mint
chocolate as you said it just keeps you
wanting more i just loved it so much and
number two
would go to
dino yeah nuggets on the bagel
everything bagel with the cream cheese i
like that one a lot too because because
of the nostalgic factor i think and then
number three would be your craft mac and
cheese okay so i remember my grandma
would make me craft mac and cheese some
days so that definitely takes number
three and then at number four sorry to
break your heart of it but no isn't it
that's totally fine this is not my
favorite but i can see myself eating
this if i have some bread with it how
about you this has got to be my favorite
for sure like i'm still eating it
because it's really good number two i'm
gonna say the cashew nut it's more like
neutral and it's easy to eat you don't
need to like saw it break things off
number three is the panseiku because
that one is like kind of peanut brittle
in the fourth just for the lack of
use you know it's got to be the
giorgioli it was really
it was really just really hard to eat
although the flavor is really nice so
that's my ring thank you for bringing me
all these like cool interesting snacks
from curacao that i would have never had
the chance to eat thank you for bringing
me into your childhood and in that way
you brought me to my childhood too yeah
i'm glad i could help you out just a
little too much cream cheese sorry a
little less cream cheese yeah
oh yes
you